[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
former new york governor andrew cuomo
charged with sexual assault angenette
levy is live with the latest from
friday's press conference and a former
gubernatorial candidate takes the stand
in his own trial for murder it was a
polite way of flipping them the bird
plus domestic violence is not always
physical what we learned about domestic
violence from the gabby potito case and
later the courtroom gets heated in the
second murder trial for markeith loyd mr
lloyd we are not listening to you right
now lawn crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome to long prime daily everybody
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
with me as always co-host terry austin
former new york governor andrew cuomo
now faces a misdemeanor criminal charge
accused of groping a former staffer but
as angenette levy tells us that charge
came as a surprise to the d.a
that's right jesse an albany county
sheriff's detective filed the criminal
complaint on thursday charging andrew
cuomo with forcible touching but the
da's office issued a statement saying
they didn't even know this was coming
they were taken aback by it david
soros's office tweeted like the rest of
the public we were surprised to learn
today that a criminal complaint was
filed in albany city court by the albany
county sheriff's office against andrew
cuomo the office of court administration
has since made that filing public
our office will not be commenting
further on this case sheriff craig apple
for his part says his agency followed
procedure by dropping off the documents
at the courts and the summons and
complaint became public more quickly
than expected now these allegations of
forcible touching involve britney camiso
a former staffer for cuomo the complaint
states cuomo placed his hand forcibly
under camiso's blouse and touched her
left breast for his own sexual
gratification you may recall cuomo
resigned after a report released by new
york attorney general leticia james
documented a number of complaints from
women against cuomo james has since
announced just recently that she is
going to run for governor but cuomo's
attorney rita glavin issued a statement
saying governor cuomo did not
assault anyone and called sheriff
apple's motives patently and proper
since the sheriff did not communicate
with the d.a about this she said this is
not professional law enforcement this is
politics sheriff apple meanwhile says
the case is solid jessie
all right let's break it down joining me
again co-host terry austin and also
former prosecutor melba pearson
melbourne i want to start with you why
would the sheriff's office file the
complaint without notifying the
prosecuting office i mean does that mean
that they don't agree on how strong this
case is
not necessarily so there could be a
number of reasons for this jesse first
off you know the the the sheriff may be
trying to keep politics out of this
right and so he may be like listen i'm
going to file these charges i'm not
going to worry about having a situation
where i tell the prosecutor's office and
then they turn around and tell me oh
don't file because
you know this is problematic for us from
a political perspective so that is one
option but i will say it is unusual
because usually the sheriff's office and
the district attorney's office of every
city have somewhat of a professional
collegial relationship and in a high
profile case of this nature and of this
magnitude you would have thought that a
heads up would have been given terry
miss camiso is claiming that cuomo
forcibly touched her legally what
exactly does that mean and what could
cuomos face in terms of jail time sex
offender registration walk me through it
well a forcible touching is a
misdemeanor jesse and the penalty would
be up to one year in jail but the
prosecution is going to have to show
that the touching was not accidental
meaning that it was intentional and also
that it was forceful
and frankly if he's convicted he would
not have to register as a sex offender
because in this case
the victim was not under 18 and it's
almost first offense if in fact he is
convicted so we'll have to see what
happens
angenet what is next for cuomo is he uh
this charge goes through i mean what's
when are we gonna see him is he gonna be
in handcuffs what's gonna happen
well uh you know this isn't a case where
you do see somebody kind of handcuffed
and arrested immediately they issued a
summons meaning
it's like a piece of paper they send it
to him and his lawyer and it says you
have to appear in
in this court on this date at this time
so he's going to appear in court on
november 17th that's when he's scheduled
to appear at that time we are told he
will be fingerprinted a mug shot will be
taken all of the things that typically
happen when someone is arrested yeah and
what's shocking to me is that when i
read that complaint how specific it was
in terms of the time frame of this
alleged incident so when i think about
that i'm thinking okay this must be
backed up by other evidence whether
surveillance footage from the executive
mansion actually laying out how long she
was there or even text messages to
corroborate this so it's going to be
very interesting to see
what this case is and what they
ultimately have presented and maybe the
da and the sheriff's office will get on
the same page all right we'll continue
to follow it on to news out of idaho
right now where a court filing alleges
unethical and possibly illegal activity
involving half of the so-called doomsday
duo the attorney for laurie valodebel
says that a state-issued clinician
persuaded her to contact the church of
jesus christ of the latter day saints
telling her it was part of her homework
for treatment court documents allege
that day bell contacted an lds attorney
and gave him important information about
her case daebel's attorney now says the
lds attorney contacted a state
prosecutor with that information acting
unethically and making a brady violation
now under a brady disclosure the
prosecution is required to disclose
exculpatory evidence about a defendant
that means that could negate the
defendant's guilt dabel's attorney now
wants to depose the lds attorney and
subpoena records from the idaho
department of health and welfare to
determine whether her rights were
violated at the time of this incident
daebel was staying at the idaho state
hospital she's now being held by the
idaho department of health and welfare
after she was deemed incompetent to
stand trial trial valodebel and her
husband chad daybell are accused of
killing her two children tyler ryan and
j.j valo the bodies of both children
were found on chadsville on chad vallo's
property chad dabel's property rather in
june 2020.
still ahead on the long crime daily
october is domestic violence awareness
month and we hear from experts who are
hoping to curb the number of cases but
first a cold case murder suspect
testifies in his own defense we take you
to colorado where a former gubernatorial
candidate is accused of kidnapping and
murder
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galvado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
and welcome back to long crime daily
everybody a colorado man takes the stand
in his own defense in an abduction and
murder cold case nearly four decades old
it's been 37 years since 12-year-old
janelle matthews went missing in her
greely colorado neighborhood matthews
was returning home in 1984 after a
school christmas concert matthews was
declared legally dead in 1994 and
remains were finally discovered in july
2019. it was then that her cause of
death was revealed as a gunshot wound to
the head
seventy or seventy-year-old stephen
panke who previously ran for governor of
idaho was a person of interest in the
case at the time of matthew's
disappearance he lived three miles from
the matthews family home and was a
pastor at her church his ex-wife told
investigators that in the days following
at the disappearance panky showed an
unusual interest in the case obsessively
reading newspaper articles and listening
to the radio reports on the case panky
was indicted by a grand jury over a year
ago for the disappearance and death of
the 12 year old panky's trial began
earlier this month on thursday the
defendant took the stand in his own
defense claiming that he did not he
didn't know the victim before learning
about her disappearance
clarify mr pinky on the night of
december 20th
1984
did you
drive to the matthews home
no i didn't know who the matthews were
though panky maintains that he didn't
know of the the victim until after she
went missing he admitted to misleading
investigators out of bitterness and
revenge for his former employer saying
he had hatred towards law enforcement
so the truth is
is is that i made a lot of stuff up
out of bitterness
for things that happened to me at
sunnyview
and for things
that happened to me at 7 up
and
my revenge on them was to
and because i hated the police it was
all in one to say
i've got information that you want and
you can't have it
it was a polite way of flipping them the
bird it was pure hatred on my part
wow okay so terry this is an odd case as
well as an old case and there's no dna
evidence linking panky to the crime do
you think that his strange behavior the
obsession about the case that is going
to be enough to convict him here
jesse i think this is going to be a very
difficult case for the prosecution first
of all you have an upstanding citizen
who ran for governor he was a pastor and
what was his motive here the fact that
there is no dna does not help the
prosecution i will say that his behavior
was quite odd the fact that he is
obsessing about the case and even his
wife testified against him they went up
to big bear lake and they came back and
he heard about it on the radio and he
wanted to stop at a safeway and get the
newspaper and he also denied having
digging in his front yard the day after
the woman disappeared so
all of his behavior is quite strange and
i think that
connecting it all together is going to
be a little bit hard for the prosecution
melba i can't think of who better to ask
this than you if you were to
cross-examine him what areas would you
hit well first of all the reality is his
story doesn't make any sense you know
why are you going to
bring in this young girl um use this
case where a young girl was
you know went missing and was murdered
and she was a member of your church
that's the case you're going to use to
politely flip off the police
it just it doesn't make sense so i would
be heavily cross-examining him on that
aspect heavily cross-examining him on
the fact that he was behaving in such a
strange manner that he was obsessed with
the case and that it doesn't make sense
that this is a member of his church and
he has no clue who she was or her family
was again it lies in the face of common
sense it's like the robert durst
syndrome i'll admit to lying on the
stand so believe me now i don't know
it's a strange one over now to a judge
ruling in favor of kobe bryant's widow
ordering la county officials to make
court depositions after
after leaking graphic images of the nba
star's deadly helicopter crash vanessa
bryan sued the county for negligence and
invasion of privacy after she claims
first responders took photos of the 2020
crash and later posted them brian his 13
year old daughter gianna and six other
people died tragically in that crash the
bryant family has made claims for
violation of civil and privacy rights as
well as emotional distress the judge's
ruling comes days after los angeles
county filed a motion that would require
bryant to undergo psychiatric evaluation
the motion also includes psychiatric
evaluation requests for all three of her
children all under the age of 14.
and coming up on law and crime daily an
argument in the courtroom where the
judge tells the defendant to be quiet
this is all in markeith lloyd's second
murder trial plus the death of gabby
potito sheds light on the dark side of
domestic violence what experts say you
should look for in warning signs all
that and more next
[Music]
and welcome back gabby petito's death
furthered the conversation about
domestic violence and how to help
victims the story consumed the news for
much of october which is domestic
violence awareness month and jeannette
levy spoke with an expert who helps the
tru helps these victims
gabby petito's father joe says he is not
focused on what may or may not be in a
notebook owned by brian laundry that was
found after he died instead he says he
is focusing on helping victims of
domestic violence
like
i guess
you didn't hit me in the basement
you've seen the body camera video
showing gabby petito during a traffic
stop after a 9-1-1 caller reported
seeing brian laundry hitting her
petito's death has renewed the
conversation about domestic violence
domestic violence is not always physical
maureen curtis works for safe horizon an
organization that helps domestic
violence victims she says domestic
violence is all about power and control
a term that's commonly used is coercive
control where a person doesn't have to
be physical but it doesn't mean that
they're not threatening curtis says
questions have been raised about how the
quote van life experience could impact a
domestic violence situation since one
tactic used by abusers is isolation and
if you're traveling around the country
if you are living in a small confined
space it's more likely that there could
be
escalated tension that could lead to
violence or escalated violence survivors
can learn lessons from petito's case but
so can those who know someone who is the
victim of domestic violence you know
stepping in um in a in a safe way to
help that person even if it's just to
talk to that person
or to listen to that person to never
underestimate how powerful how powerful
that can be there is a national domestic
violence hotline that's open 24 7. the
number is 1-800-799
safe
for law and crime daily i'm angenette
levy
so important in south carolina now a
monumental settlement is reached as the
department of justice grants 88 million
dollars to the families of the charlton
church massacre the settlement funds
range between six million and seven and
a half million dollars per claim and 5
million dollars for survivors all this
comes after a lawsuit brought to the doj
over the shooter's purchase of the
weapon dylan roof was convicted of
federal murder in 2016 after he opened
fire at a historically black church in
charleston nine people were killed and
one other was injured in 2019 the
federal court of appeals ruled that the
families could sue the government for
negligence after multiple lapses in
background checks that allowed roof to
purchase the semi-automatic pistol that
he used in 2017 roof was sentenced to
death for his crimes
well this week on the long crime
network's podcast cocktails and
cocktails sergeant shawn sticks-larkin
sits down with lieutenant jeffrey postal
the once rookie officer who caught the
man who set off a bomb at the 1996
olympics in atlanta
and as i came around the corner of the
building i saw an individual kind of
crouched down in the roadway
as if they were kind of sneaking or if
you will going towards the the rear of
the business
2 30 3 o'clock 3 30 in the morning uh
there's not a lot going on in those
businesses and
and i always said there's only two types
of people out at that time especially
behind the business cops and crooks
and i know i was the only cop on duty at
that time so i knew that he wasn't a
friend
what a hero you can listen to this
week's cocktails and cocktails episode
now on apple podcast or wherever
podcasts can be found when we come back
the courtroom heats up in the second
murder trial for markeith loyd we take
you inside the florida courtroom to hear
the argument between the defense
attorney and the judge about a charge
that is nearly 20 years old
[Music]
welcome back in florida the defense
begins its case in the second murder
trial for markeith loyd the state rested
on thursday after only a few days of
testimony lloyd is on trial for the
murder of lieutenant debra clayton who
was killed while attempting to arrest
the defendant outside of a walmart lloyd
was previously charged and convicted for
the murder of his pregnant ex-girlfriend
shaw day dixon in that case he avoided
the death penalty and was sentenced to
life in prison lloyd has a long history
of conviction stretching back to 1994
with over 20 arrests however if
convicted in this case lloyd will face
the death penalty again lloyd was also
found guilty back in 2002 for attacking
a corrections officer while that at that
time in jail for another charge the
state wanted to bring this case into
evidence to establish a history of
violence with lloyd but the defense
began their case with testimony on
friday and before before calling any
witnesses the defense argued against
including this evidence
so
but there's no evidence of a violence
hold on let me finish thank you
where it says a mutiny is occurs
that's that's what it says is occurs
when inmates acting together
resist a prison warden or his
subordinate officers in the free and
lawful exercise
of their legal authority
so would not
slamming an officer to the ground
constitute a mutiny
absolutely absolutely not
because what do you have some law that
says that because that's just your
choice
mr lloyd we are not listening to you
right now go ahead
but maybe they will listen to them
because melba we're hearing rumblings
that the defendant himself may testify
like he did in his first trial how would
that help or hurt his case
well you know defendants testifying
aren't always the best idea from the
standpoint of you know you're nervous
you may not come across as eloquently as
you would like or get all the points
that you would like across and of course
you're opening up to cross-examination
where a prosecutor can completely
dismantle you but the fact of the matter
is this is a case that's about his
mental state and he has basically used
the defense of insanity saying he didn't
understand right from wrong at the time
that he killed the um this poor officer
so if he comes on the stand and seems
kind of out there and really scattered
that could also play into the defense's
argument towards insanity and terry
aside from him taking the stand the
defense called a few witnesses how do
you think their case is progressing so
far i don't think they're making very
good legal arguments and they aren't
bringing on very good witnesses the
first witness was a private investigator
he couldn't even remember when he came
to take the pictures at the walmart and
in fact on cross-examination it was
demonstrated that it took him two and a
half years to take those pictures and
the second witness wasn't that good
either she was trying to say that there
were strike marks on the wall at walmart
but i don't think the jury is going to
care about that all of officer clayton's
bullets missed and in fact she was shot
four times and they're trying to
establish that she fired first uh you
know we'll wait and see melba terry
thank you so much everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on long crime
daily we're gonna see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you